[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new Marvel video for all the
Fantastic Four Easter eggs in the MCU in
Marvel movies so far there have actually
been several we found out about a couple
that are coming through the Disney Plus
series that are going to be airing next
year so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite fantastic for
Easter Egg from any MCU movie on the
video so we'll do the top ten there's
also an eleventh bonus Easter Egg too so
technically there's 11 but we'll start
with number 10 Kang the Conqueror from
the new Loki series on Disney Plus most
people know King the conquer is a
time-travel villain from The Young
Avengers comics or from the straight up
Avengers comics because that's the way
they've been using it most recently but
he actually started out as a Fantastic
Four villain called Rama Tut in 1963 a
full year before he started fighting the
Avengers in their comic book K himself
is actually a descendant of Reed
Richards from the 30th century so he's
actually biologically related to mr.
fantastic of the Fantastic Four
Kang's real name is actually Nathaniel
Richards he gave himself the name came
to conquer when he eventually took that
mantle
Reed Richards father Nathaniel Richards
from the main Marvel 6-1-6 universe had
his family with Reed Richards but he was
also a scientist he also tried to travel
the multiverse eventually he
successfully traveled to another reality
save that earth and then eventually had
another family than many generations
later in the 30th century his descendant
was named Nathaniel Richards to honor
him that boy is the one who became King
the conquer so not only as came to
conquer a big time travel villain he's
also a big multiverse villain they're
obviously relying a lot on multiverse
travel and time travel for the Loki
series so it makes sense they would try
to set up the concept of Kang the
Conqueror on that series we're all
thinking about alternate versions of
Loki like kid Loki or female Loki
showing up because it's a multiverse
story on that series King the conquer is
also a character who spends a lot of
time interacting with other versions of
himself at various points in his
timeline no I don't think that oh and
Wilson is playing Kang they did just
asked Richard E Grant who plays great
villains in everything that he does but
they didn't say who he's playing either
there will be a lot of multiverse
villains showing up on that series
because the time variants authority so
number 9 next big Fantastic Four Easter
Egg the time variants authority they
spend a lot of time trying to chase down
Reed Richards in the Fantastic Four
because they do so much multiverse
travel to most of the time when you're
talking about Fantastic Four in the
multiverse you're either talking about
Franklin Richards creating alternate
realities or you're talking about Reed
Richards finding the negative zone or
you're talking about the maker who's the
evil Reed Richards from another
alternate reality the time various
Authority are sort of like the Time
Lords of the Marvel Universe but as you
can see in these pictures
Loki seems like he's going to be an
agent or forced to help the time variant
authority through his series number
eight is the Minutemen they're all so
big Fantastic Four characters that are
also part of the time variance Authority
they'll probably be chasing down Loki at
some point but they're basically like
robots so imagine if the Time Lords from
Doctor Who co-opted the Cybermen and
used them to travel the multiverse and
chase down villains to try and capture
them and lock them up there's a bunch of
Easter eggs and spider-man far from home
most recently so number seven there's
the Construction sign with a one two
three four we can't wait to show you
what's coming next this is one of those
cool Easter eggs that references a bunch
of different things it's a Marvel phase
for Easter Egg because it's phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 in phase 4 but you
notice that each of the numbers also
corresponds to the different colors of
the powers of the Fantastic Four and
obviously that 4 is invisible because of
the Invisible Woman number 6 the
location where spider-man and MJ are
standing on that street corner is just a
couple blocks from where the Baxter
building has been in the Marvel Comics
and so number 5 everyone wondering who
the secret buyer is behind the New
Avengers Tower it makes sense that
eventually they would want to turn the
Avengers tower because that's moved
upstate and obviously now they blown up
that facility so they're gonna have to
rebuild a new Avengers base when they do
a new Avengers movie but how fitting
that they eventually turn the classic
Avengers tower of the MCU into the
Baxter building replacing what you would
consider the giant a symbol with the
four symbol what
the Fantastic Four team comes together
because they haven't introduced the
actual Fantastic Four characters on
screen yet we don't really know how old
they are in present day the 2023 after
Avengers endgame we don't know what
they're doing and we don't know when
they're actually going to become the
family of the Fantastic Four even though
I don't really consider it in Easter Egg
you can actually think about Nick Fury's
sword spacestation from the comics it'd
be very easy to do their comic book
backstory if you just make them agents
of sword scientists working for Nick
Fury on that Space Station and it gets
hit by cosmic rays like the Fantastic
Four did in the comics and that's how
they get their powers they're actually a
couple Fantastic Four references during
Avengers infinity war number four when
Doctor Strange is using the time stone
to look into the future he's looking
into fourteen million six hundred and
five thousand possibilities think about
the number four in 605 in Fantastic Four
issue 605 it features Reed Richards
building a machine that will allow him
to see all the possible futures of the
Fantastic Four exactly the same way
Doctor Strange uses the time stone to
examine all their possible futures to
find one where they can beat Thanos so
it's no coincidence that they pick that
number when dr. strange was talking
about their possible futures they could
have picked any number they could have
said one of a billion possibilities
number three the other big Fantastic
Four reference is actually in the
guardians of the galaxy intro scene with
the song that they used so when the
guardians are introduced for the first
time they arrive to the rubberband man
by the spinners James Gunn gave the
Russos a list of songs from the 1970s to
keep the Guardians on brand when they
were in the movie the Russos could have
picked any one of those songs and any
part of any one of those songs because
they only use part of the song they
don't play the entire song when they
come in they very carefully selected the
lyrics prepare yourself for the rubber
band band the rubber band man is
actually the nickname that the thing
uses for Reed Richards so just a sly
reference to the Fantastic Four number
two there's a big meta easter egg during
ant-man and the wasp most people think
about the quantum realm being a bit of a
fantastic for easter egg because of the
negative zone in Reed Richards but this
is actually more of a funny Easter egg
tim heidecker
from ant-man the wasp cameoed as the
toward captain his scene was whittled
way down in the theatrical cut so he's
really just in the background he's a
friend of the director Peyton Reed he
has a podcast with his co-host Craig
turkleton who also is involved in a bit
of a cameo contest with all of them as
part of that contest he also paid to
have himself cameo in Josh Trank's
Fantastic Four back in 2015 is Reed
Richards abusive father but bringing it
back around to Fantastic Four before
Peyton Reed was hired to direct the
first ant-man movie way way back years
earlier when he was working at Fox he
was developing his own Fantastic Four
movie we're talking early 2000s around
the time spider-man 2 with Tobey Maguire
was coming out in theaters this was way
before the Tim story Chris Evans
fantastic for movies his version of the
Fantastic Four movie was going to be set
during the 1960s and was not going to be
a straight-up origin story like all
those early og 2000s x-men and
spider-man movies were hopefully when
Marvel gets around to releasing a new
Fantastic Four film they'll find a
clever way to reference Chris Evans
Human Torch and his Captain America
character
speaking of which next big Fantastic
Four Easter egg in the MCU is in Captain
America the First Avenger the beginning
of that movie features a cameo scene
with the original Human Torch character
it just shows up in a display so
obviously that's them sort of trying to
play on the joke of Chris Evans being
the Human Torch in the fantastic four
movies the really cool thing about that
version of the Human Torch the original
version is that his comic book stories
also feature the very first huge Marvel
character crossover story when he and
Namor crossed over name wars Atlantis
also shows up on a map during Iron Man
two near Wakanda here behind them when
Nick Fury is telling Iron Man about the
Avengers and how he's not totally fit
for duty also important distinction
Namor is referred to as the first mutant
because he debuted in the comics before
any of the other Marvel mutant based
characters before the x-men and before
the Fantastic Four characters were
created way back at Comic Con Kevin
Feige was actually referring to the Fox
Marvel characters collectively as
mutants and that includes the Fantastic
Four characters which might give you
some idea for how he's thinking about
them inside the MCU and because of that
distinction of the Fantastic Four
technically being
mutants number one there's actually
fantastic for reference during the first
Iron Man movie there was a deleted scene
version of the Iron Man 1 post-credit
scene with Nick Fury telling Iron Man
about the Avengers when he shows up any
references mutants x-men the Fantastic
Four and spider-man years before any of
those characters were ever going to
enter the MCU and some still haven't
come like the Fantastic Four
mutants weren't enough I have to deal
with a spoiled brat doesn't play well
with others and wants to keep all his
toys to himself right now John Krasinski
is still campaigning to be Reed Richards
so hopefully Marvel makes him an offer
if they haven't already
rina the early rumor is is that Marvel
is gonna try and release their new
Fantastic Four movies sometime 2022 or
2023 but obviously because the virus
shut down and things being delayed a lot
of the timeline could change just a
little bit things might get pushed down
the road
but let me know in the comments if you
spotted any big Fantastic Four Easter
eggs or references in MCU movies that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments
everyone click here to learn about all
the Marvel movies that have been delayed
or canceled recently and click here to
learn all about ahsoka tano coming to
the mandalorian season 2 thank you so
much for watching everyone stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight